it's time for another gaming news show
and today we're talking about how
blizzard has officially scrapped the
long-awaited PVE hero mode in OverWatch
2. on a twitch stream explaining the
game's roadmap the executive producer
said development on the PVE experience
has not really made the progress that we
had hoped the team has created a bunch
of amazing content so there's awesome
missions that are really exciting
there's brand new enemies that are super
fun to fight and some truly great and
ridiculous hero talents but
unfortunately the effort required to
pull all of that together into a
blizzard quality experience that we can
ship to you is huge and there really is
no end in sight or defined kind of an
end date where we can put that out into
the world and so we are left with
another difficult Choice it's clear that
we can't deliver on the original vision
for PVE that was shown in 2019 and what
that means is that we won't be
delivering that dedicated hero mode with
talent trees that long-term Talent power
progression those things are just not in
our plans anymore of course this
inspired a lot of conversation about
OverWatch 2 and the actual value of the
game with a lot of commenters saying it
probably could have been DLC